welcome to scitrek your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
this week i'm going to be looking at one
of the most iconic names in all of
sci-fi
the starship enterprise so the name of
this video is the good the bad and the
ugly commas enterprise j we'll get to
that a little while later
but i really want to talk and compare
all of the different iterations of the
starship enterprise that we've seen in
canon and a little bit of uh off cannon
and we've got to start obviously with
the original
the nx
the nx01 the star check enterprise
annoyed the crap out of me when this
series came out primarily because the
first enterprise is the enterprise
1701 captained by pike and then kirk
they shoehorned this whole ship this nx
class
into the star trek canon simply because
they wanted to call this series
enterprise they could have called this
starship anything else
they could endeavor colombia something
like that they could have called this
ship anything but they insisted on
calling it enterprise i always really
like the design of this ship i think
it's actually really nicely done i think
it really shows an evolution
from sort of like
the very early stages into what they
would then become the 1701
and i thought they did a really really
nice job of sort of showing that
progression and keeping the technology
reasonable something they didn't bother
doing when they did discovery they just
went well it's just great something
crazy and if you look at this other
vessel this refit vessel that was always
planned for serious five which god i
wish they'd done it in series four would
have made so much more sense and might
have even saved the show they really
showed a progression towards making this
vessel look a little bit more like a
constitution it showed where the
federation and starfleet would then go
with starship designs
i really wish we'd seen that we never
got to but
it
was a lovely looking ship they got
everything right with the design
they just should never have called it
enterprise
but moving on to the actual
original enterprise 1701
the constitution class is
in its original form not the best
looking ship in the world but
the refit for the movies genuinely i
consider to be one of the finest
starship designs in all of sci-fi
it is a gorgeous looking ship it looks
like it's doing a hundred mile an hour
and it stood still it's just a brilliant
design
one of the major things for the refit
obviously we saw in the motion picture
is a complete redesign of this vessel
most importantly a massive upgrade to
its shields
three klingon battle cruisers were wiped
out by vega they didn't even have a
chance they were completely
disintegrated whereas the enterprise was
able to take one or two hits
this really showed a quantum leap in
shield design technology for the
federation this was really the point i
think when the federation overtook the
klingons in ship design 289 meters long
and 21 or 23 decks depending on which
user manual you read
the enterprise was a pretty big ship
remember in the enterprise e only had 24
decks so i mean
from a height point of view
not a small vessel not however as big as
the jj abrams shot at the enterprise
that ship was freaking enormous jj
abrams took the enterprise and just said
we can't have that on an imax this'll
look stupid so they made the enterprise
for the kelvin timeline enormous 700 and
something meters long actually makes it
significantly bigger than even the e
this design was completely stupid but
not the worst thing about the enterprise
from the calvin timeline
the warp core particularly in the first
movie is completely confusing we
actually see the warp core at one point
but then he ejects it towards the end of
the film and they shoot out loads of
little warp cores don't really know why
the whole ship seems to be water powered
for someone who seems to be
hydroelectric or something i mean you
look at all the water pipes and they i
think they did all that just to have
that one joke where um scotty get
accidentally gets beamed into a water
pipe you just see it goes through past
um but it seems to be hydroelectric so
strange
um
but
lens flares aside
the design of this enterprise is
horrible
i don't like it i don't like the engines
i think they look stupid
and i just all over this ship is just
horrible
i hate this ship even though i actually
quite like the movies i don't really
consider them star trek if i'm honest
but i quite like the movies but this
ship
i hate it
[Music]
moving quickly into the 1701a
after the original enterprise was
destroyed we quickly got a new
enterprise
constitution class again it was actually
another vessel that was renamed and
reclassed so that it could um so kurt
could take command and get back out
there pretty quick this is one of the
ships that we actually see very very
little off
it almost gets no screen time really and
well we moved into the enterprise b
pretty quickly
even though obviously on the enterprise
b
everything was fit on tuesday
[Music]
now that was a great joke
but how do you fit
everything on tuesday the tractor beam
system is quite a big piece of
technology that may be finished on
tuesday not fit on tuesday never really
made sense
now we see almost none of the enterprise
b in canon we only really see it at the
beginning generations but the excelsior
class is obviously one of the most
successful starships ever designed by
the federation this ship survives well
into the next generation sort of class
we see it again in deep space nine it
was a mainstay of the battle against the
dominion this is one of the most capable
ship designs of any ship we've ever seen
even though the grand experiment sort of
failed with its trans warp capabilities
allegedly
the vessel was designed to be a very
capable all-around starship it had an
incredibly strong superstructure and
that really showed throughout its
survivability the vessel lasted for over
200 years and was still in regular
frontline use in yesterday's enterprise
we saw the enterprise sea
an ambassador class starship not a
starship we really see a great deal of
across the enterprise franchise but i
actually thought a really lovely design
this is one of the first times we ever
really see a female captain captain
harry man
and this vessel was really really
important in the peace negotiations
between the klingons
and the federation the second kitten
records the kitten recorded actually
stuck this time
the klingons and basically became an
extension of the federation really by
tng
and that alliance really really saved
the federation during the dominion war
even though
it went wrong a few times
the enterprise sea really does hold its
place within the federation as one of
the most important starships really in
its history
even though we don't see a great deal of
it
and i love the tashiar story just just
love it
then we get into probably
my favorite enterprise but but because
of my age
i've seen the original series but i was
a bit young
when the next generation came out i was
11 or 12 my formative years of sci-fi
was watching the next generation
i loved the galaxy class starship i had
the manual i read all about it
you know that there are dolphins aboard
the enterprise i knew that 15 years ago
because i scoured
that
handbook front to back
[Music]
641 meters long
over 40 decks
this ship was enormous the galaxy class
has been able to separate the sources
section the calypso the captain shot
that we never got to see but i really
wish we had done it is really from the
golden age of the federation when the
federation was in a period of peace
before the borg invasion when we saw
families removed from the enterprise
and all other federation starships the
galaxy class really was
a family vessel in lots of ways it was a
mobile community a mobile city
and it was just a beautiful design
they took the constitution class and
they made everything bigger better
it's again streamlined design fast even
when it's stood still
i love the way it used to have to sweep
in lines and and the
phaser banks that would go
i just love everything about this
starship it will always be my favorite
and it will always have a little place
right in there
but i have to say when i first saw the
enterprise e i was in the cinema i'd
gone to see the star trek films back to
back so it was about six o'clock in the
morning and this was the first time i'd
seen this movie i remember this is
really before the internet and things so
i hadn't seen any hints of what the new
enterprise was going to look like
and when we have the opening shot and it
sweeps across
everybody in the cinema went uh
it was actually audible and i'm british
we don't shout and yell and get all over
excited about things we are very very
like
stiff upper lip and all that so for
everyone to actually go huh that was
that was like a massive outburst of
emotion for us
it's a gorgeous ship it's it is
battling with the galaxy class from my
favorite really
24 decks or 26 or 29 or
more depending on
cannon if you believe picard has got 24
should believe wharf has got 26 if you
believe riker's got 29 and if you
believe the schematic on the back of the
wall it's only got 23
but
is one of the most powerful vessels
built as its time it's a multi-purpose
vessel it's not focused like the defied
it is a classic federation multi-purpose
capable vessel
but it is
stunningly capable
again it looks like it's doing warp 10
when it stood still
it's
very well armed very well very powerful
vessel for its size even though it got
its ass handed to it by shinzon if you
actually look if you actually think
about that battle
three romulan warbirds get wiped out
the enterprise loses that battle until
picard does a suicide mission but
the enterprise held its own much much
better against a much bigger much better
armed scimitar
the enterprise is an incredibly capable
fighting machine as well as science
vessel and explorer
685 meters long the sovereign class is
just beautiful now we're getting off
canon here a little bit for the
enterprise f
[Music]
now
this has appeared
in the comics that ran up to the new
card series
1041 meters long i love the design of
the ship and it really came from star
trek online there was a competition to
design the next enterprise and this
modified version of this vessel was what
was the winning design basically
a lot of people have said this is a
horrendous living vessel and i don't
agree i love the way the neck is
one design flaw a lot of the time with
the enterprise is that it actually does
have structural weak points
the neck between the saucer and the body
section is incredibly weak we've seen
that exploited in a couple of movies
when the enterprise has been destroyed
no more so than um the more recent star
trek film the warping cells as well
again the struts for the water cells
incredibly weak points in this design
actually as a starship as a fighting
machine
the enterprise really is flawed
there's no reason for it to have this
shape other than it looks incredible and
it's a design philosophy that they've
gone with but really you could just make
a starship
a box with engines sticking out the back
and a ball cube basically and it would
be far stronger far more structurally
sound there's no reason for it to be
aerodynamic and pretty
um so in lots of ways the design of the
enterprise is stupid
the enterprise f
really gets around a lot of those design
problems the double neck between the
section thing is much stronger much
sturdy
we don't know much about this vessel but
i do suspect we might see it in picard
series 2. three more enterprises that
we've never seen there is no cannon we
know nothing about them g the h and the
eye we've never seen that we know
nothing about them
but we have seen and his cannon the j
and it's the ugliest starship ever
designed
[Music]
[Music]
it's ridiculous and it looks stupid it
should be called the uss definitely
going to break because it's got this
stupid little fragile warp engine
sticking out back with a little bit it
just looks stupid it's enormous
it's over 3000 meters long and nearly 3
000 meters wide
we know nothing about its armor we know
very little about the actual starship
except
we know it was launched in roughly the
26th century
we know
that apparently the federation hasn't
really technologically advanced at all
lots of starships in the federation
universe don't have a deflector dish but
the enterprise j still does
most employees have much better engine
designs than the enterprise j it seems
in most ways the technology just paused
for like 300 years
um all they really did was make it much
much bigger
and like i said the design for where the
warp engines are
it just looks stupid
we can assume this vessel would be
transwarp capable and it is really a
flying city
we can assume it's very well armed for
everything else the federation is still
pretty strong at this point um but in
lots and lots of ways this vessel makes
no sense i think it was a design that
was thrown together for the enterprise
series and i think in hindsight
the the designers of this probably
regret it
a really really ugly ship
and that really is the good the bad and
the
[ __ ] ugly
of all our starship enterprises
if you are new to my channel please like
subscribe hit that bell notification i
am going to be doing videos looking far
more detail all the different iterations
of the starship enterprise and all those
little secrets and details that we us
nerds love to get stuck into
but if you are new to the channel please
like and subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps us out and
leave a comment which is your favorite
enterprise and which is the enterprise
that you really really maybe don't like
so much
i'll see you next time
[Music]